foreign
live from the headquarters of Ramsay
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show where we help people build
wealth do work that they love and create
actual amazing relationships Jade wash
all Ramsey personality is my co-host
today as we answer your questions about
your life and your money the phone
number is AAA
825-5225 Chris is in Spokane hi Chris
welcome to the Ramsay show
hello thank you for taking my call it is
a privilege honor to speak to you sir
how can we help
first I've learned a lot from you in the
last couple years more than I ever
learned in the college degree so thank
you that my dilemma right now is with my
work and obtaining the backup vehicle I
am an independent contractor and drives
a lot of miles or repairs are part of
the deal and my original means uh was
taken away from me a few months ago and
so now I'm looking for a way to get a
backup vehicle a way to finance and
repairs and it's been wishy-washy I used
to be able to take it to the dealership
it has a third party contractor or I
could work on financing give me a loaner
that's all gone now so I'm back to
square one if I go hit my car break down
how do I get a vehicle uh save it up for
it's difficult I took out a couple
credit cards and they're under control
but I still need that resource back so I
don't know how to do that
what kind of delivery driving are you
doing can I have some clarity on that
yeah I've done the Uber list doordash
I've been got thousands of deliveries
done under it so is there anything wrong
with your current vehicle or you just
want this just in case
just in case
I mean so how much do you make
about 5 000 a month okay
well in in business uh if you were
running a business which you are you're
an independent subcontractor right or an
independent contractor so if you've
let's say you had a heating and air
company that and you had 10 trucks that
were fixing people's Heating and Air
one of the things we would teach you in
business is to set aside a percentage of
your profits for truck replacement
and then as and eventually you'd have
enough to buy a truck and then you start
the process again and so ever so many
years you would roll a truck off of your
Fleet and roll a new one on but you've
been systematically saving a percentage
of your profits if you save 10 of your
of your five thousand as an example
that'd be 500 that'd be six thousand
dollars a year I mean you could buy
another six thousand dollar car once a
year
and that's all you need for a backup car
yeah I don't think Chris that you need
two vehicles at one time I think this is
more about I'm saving up I've got this
money here to replace the vehicle you've
got or upgrade when the time comes or
fix the repairs as as needed but making
five thousand a month I don't see why
you need two vehicles one sitting in the
driveway and the other one that you're
driving if you did it's super
inexpensive one I mean it's just above
hoopty level because you don't you don't
need you definitely definitely don't
need two fifteen thousand dollar
vehicles to drive Uber that'd be dumb
okay all right even if they're all paid
for and it with with the income you're
producing it doesn't justify that so um
but yeah I I would it's okay to put a
hoopty or somehowty in the in the yard
if you want or the driveway if you want
to have as your back up uh and then
you've got to have repairs in your line
items because basically you are running
the wheels off a car and so you're going
to have increased repairs because the
miles are putting on it and you got to
increase fuel cost and you've got to run
all of that in your in your uh basically
the profit and loss statement of your
business which is the revenue that comes
in minus fuel minus repairs minus
vehicle replacement
um and those are the the line items in
in your business's budget and then the
net of that is taxable and the net of
that is what you really are taking home
you can't take a hundred percent of it
home because you're constantly be in a
Lurch on repairs you'll constantly be in
a Lurch on vehicle replacement so you've
got to systematize this and and just
build you a process and I don't care
what it is if if the 500 I mentioned is
enough then that's fine and you say okay
we're going to sit you also need to be
setting your tax money aside every month
that's a fact you know so you know your
quarterly estimates on taxes which about
25 percent of your profits and uh so you
need to set that aside and set aside
vehicle replacement and set aside car
repairs and so you've got these little
miniature
savings accounts for replacement and for
repairs and then you can run the thing
efficiently that's how you handle the
cash flow aspect of this and then the
other thing you need to ask yourself is
what Jade's saying is you know how much
do we really need to invest in this well
you know and that's what I said if he's
really focused on
Uber side of things or the Lyft side of
things it might be more profitable for
him to increase the value of the car
that he's driving because you are you
can earn more based on the type of
vehicle that you have so I don't know I
mean it may be worth him running those
numbers out but you know maybe you drive
the hoopty for like instacart type stuff
but you're saving up to buy you know a
certain level of vehicle so that you can
make more on your Uber and Lyft stuff
he's got he's got to price that stuff
out and see see where the the true money
lies the black SUV level yeah well
that's going to take him a minute at
5000 a month but you know 500 a month
yeah yeah however you did it exactly
Tammy's with us Tammy's in Jacksonville
Florida hi Tammy how are you
I'm good how are you better than we
deserve what's up awesome well I'm I'm
for some Godly Financial wisdom we are
in a situation
um you know we took Financial Peace
University many years ago and and really
put it to work
um we live in a small rural community
and our pastors so we have done the best
we can with with what we got well our
insurance company has canceled us
because
um we they're requiring us to get a new
roof because our roof is about 23 years
old
um it's actually still in good condition
we could replace those ourselves
um but the second insurance company just
canceled us again and we only owe about
forty two thousand dollars on our
mortgage we are trying to figure out do
we
do we try somehow to pay off the
mortgage whether it be through
um a personal loan or the minimum like
we could drain our savings and pay off
the um that with a little bit of a
personal loan and not have to worry
about a roof
um
or or go into debt to get the roof
how much do you have in savings
we have about twenty three thousand
dollars in savings and we have um so you
have the money to fix you have the money
to put a roof on the house
we do do it but the other day your house
needs a roof
right right but the but what we're being
told by our broker that even with a new
roof they won't be able to find anybody
to insure us why because I get a new
broker we don't
we don't have we don't have a um fire
department near us you had Insurance
before and there was no fire department
near you
no there was
they closed closed down yes they just
closed down like I said we're in a very
rural community and so we're very
confused with what everybody's telling
us yeah I'm gonna work this problem and
I think you need to put a roof on your
house and get get insurance and then
work to get your house paid off
um I'm with you on getting it paid off
but you know you're not really you're
just moving the loan to a personal loan
if you did that it's not the end of the
world so if you throw 20 at it and you
go take a 20 000 personal loan now
you're free but you still need a roof
and you still need insurance
after the Smoke Clears on that no pun
intended
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees ever
either one 100 percent satisfaction
guarantee and shipping is always free
see why blinds.com is the number one
online retailer of custom window
coverings go to blinds.com now and save
40 off selected products visit
blinds.com today for more info
[Music]
Jade warshaw Ramsay personality is my
co-host today thank you for joining us
America we're glad you're here the phone
number is triple eight eight two five
five two two five our question of the
day is sponsored by neighborly your hub
for Home Services if you're moving you
have a long list of to Do's but
neighborly has local Pros like house
Master the ground Skies five-star
painting and Junk King to check items
off that list visit neighborly.com today
to schedule Home Service Experts near
you all right today's question comes
from Jessie in the baby steps
millionaire group he says I'm 61 years
old I'm hoping to retire soon but
watching my retirement savings go down
day after day after day the only part
not going down is a hundred and eighty
thousand dollars sitting in the bank
earning almost zero interest but not
completely eroding away with the stock
market what should I do who I like this
question
um
for many reasons number one Jesse
um you're forgetting that the money
that's just sitting in the bank it you
know you're not it does it's not earning
interest like it would in the stock
market but there is a little thing
called inflation
and that is affecting your savings
that's just sitting there so I'm just
putting that out there but let's talk
about this retirement savings because
you're telling me that it's quote
completely eroding away and that's
that's just not true bull yeah that's
just not true the stock market is
down
but it's not completely eroding away and
it will come back up we know that we you
can look at the track record and know
that this is temporary the stock market
is cyclical it goes down and it goes up
so
Jesse one of the things you have to
understand and it helped me because I
actually got into the research
um about 30 years ago on this is that uh
we all especially when it comes to
investing but a lot of other things too
we all have a drama queen that lives in
our brain
that exaggerates everything and oh God
you know thing okay and uh
that
the studies have told us now that it
takes three dollars of gain in an
investment to emotionally offset one
dollar of loss hmm our brain records
negative things
at a much greater rate
and it takes a while it takes a lot of
emotion to recover from that and so what
I'm saying is is that Jade is exactly
right your drama queen wrote this email
okay completely
terrible look okay it's down maybe 10
but I mean so if you got a million
dollars now it's worth nine hundred
thousand and next year it'll be worth a
million three I mean I mean me and one I
mean whatever it's just so it's not
completely eroding away so because Jesse
here's another way of knowing that have
you ever heard people say this I lost
all my money in the stock market
mathematically impossible
it just didn't happen you didn't lose
all your money in the stock market
unless you put it all in one company and
that company completely closed yeah
and was worth zero if you put all your
money in Enron
you lost all your money in the stock
market certain cryptocurrencies yeah
well that's probably even the stock
market right that's true you know but it
would have but but you know but what
people really mean is I lost a bunch of
money I freaked out I went into hyper
drama mode I pulled my money out at
exactly the wrong time while it was down
and then bitched about it for the next
decade that's what we really mean when
you say I lost all my money and stuff
you didn't lose all your money in stock
market so in 2008 the market went from
000 out of 6500 went in half
and the number of people that will tell
you they lost everything in the stock
market in 2008 is amazing because and
they're all wrong you just didn't you if
you
had if you put it in at 13 and with 6
500 you have the world's worst possible
timing you pulled it out at the bottom
and if you did that you lost the most
you could have possibly lost in recent
memory right in 100 years almost
not 100 but 80 yeah 80 years okay and um
and even in that event you only lost
half your money that's right you put a
hundred thousand in and went to 6500
worth 50 Grand and by the way I put
money in at 13. I didn't take it out at
all and guess what the 6500 is worth now
it's a 38 000 right and so you know five
if you so if you had a million at the
bottom you got five or six million now
wow you just you got to look in the
mirror and tell yourself the truth I got
to tell this story my my son this is
exactly what this reminds me of uh my
son is five and I do his hair for him
every morning because he's got curly
hair and I have to spray it down with
water and he hates that and today I have
to do that do you to just keep the shine
going
Dave a little drip of water drips from
his hair like onto a shirt and he's like
look at me I've got water
yeah yeah that's it and I'm like you
have one drip of water on your shirt and
I made him look I said look in the
mirror and say there's not water all
over me there's water there's a trip of
water on my shirt and he said he said it
in the mirror and then I said and now
now say
spraying water on my hair is part of the
process and sometimes water gets on my
shirt and he said it and I think that's
what this is you got to know when you
invest in the stock market part of the
process is it goes up and it goes down
and you're not completely eroding and
getting I'm completely drenched you
gotta Dr it drips all right like you
gotta look sometimes you just gotta tell
yourself the truth exactly right and and
just accept it facts and Mathematics are
your friends to tell your drama queen
and all of us have one and so we have to
do that we have to do the facts to tell
our drama queen to shut up yeah we're
going to continue to invest and no I'm
not got 180 000 sitting in the bank
wondering why it's not going up because
I know it's not that ain't doing I'm not
doing squats he's tripping he thinks
that money's doing well that's losing
value too right now that's just every
single down year in the stock market's
history but one is followed by a record
two-year rise
wow so if you're out right now
historically
you're stupid
that's what history that's not so good
hysterically historically ah there's a
difference right there you need to use
history not hysteria and that's the
thing because Jesse all of us do this
the other one that goes with Jesse's
thing here that I run into and I run
into this sometimes when we're doing a
media appearance too is what are retired
people going to do this stock market is
down how are they going to
well
they weren't going to cash all their
money out this year anyway right right
if you've got a half million dollars in
your 401k you're not going to run over
and cash it out this year unless you
panic and you probably weren't planning
to cash it out you're probably just
going to live off of the income that it
creates and not even touch the principle
well that's so let the principal ride
the roller coaster and just let your
income a reasonable income come off of
it and retired people are just fine that
way but broke people when they retire
they don't have fun even in up markets
that's true that's true because you
never had it to begin with now Jesse you
said that you're still working you
haven't retired yet so keep investing
now is a great time to buy get the 180
000 invested right now dude I don't time
the market but I'm telling you every
down Market bear Market that it holds
out as long as this one has held out is
followed by a two-year upturn that's
good to accept one every single one of
them what was the exception do you know
no not off the top of my head I was
looking at the charts the other day it
might have been a weight
well it might have taken it more than
two years to recover it might have been
I think there were two down years in a
row there and that's what throws that
number off if I remember right but I
mean you go back and look where we've
had because usually what happens too
around this is election cycle that's a
very good so think about what the
election cycle is by this time next year
we are sick of presidential
by this time next year you're going to
be so sick of politics because you're
going to be right Square in the middle
of a booming presidential election and
guess what that does to the stock market
hello it gives it hope that's true and
hope is all the stock market needs to go
up and so just just hang on when when
the leaves get green next spring
all these companies out there are not
losing money they're all making money
guess where stock price comes from
profit and potential profit and
projected and forecasted profit and
that's all still there this is the
Ramsey Show
[Music]
[Applause]
we've been doing business at Ramsey for
more than 30 years by now we're a
well-oiled machine but it wasn't always
that way yes we've always had a vision
always had determination and a drive to
help people but what we didn't have was
one central place to access all our
numbers so that we could get further
ahead or quickly see when we needed to
Pivot we were always jumping back and
forth between different systems and
spreadsheets so when netsuite by Oracle
helped us Wrangle our Revenue inventory
expenses and more into one place it was
a game changer and netsuite's number one
Cloud Financial system can help your
business gain the same visibility
because businesses thrive on timely data
and netsuite's real-time analytics can
help your business have immediate access
to your numbers daily so you always know
where you stand and you can move quickly
so go to netsuite.com Ramsey today and
set up a free product tour that's
netsuite.com Ramsey
[Music]
foreign
let's do a little mental exercise
look out 90 days from right now it's
July
you got a thousand dollars sitting in
the bank two of your credit card
payments are gone and you check out at
the grocery store without having a panic
attack
you know how that would feel
like Financial Peace
some of you have never had that in your
entire life but today's the day you can
get control of your money
starts with a thing called Financial
Peace University it's our nine week
course it's helped millions of people
beat debt build wealth and become
outrageously generous
and we're going to teach you everything
about how to handle money step by step
and here's how fast things can change
the average Financial Peace University
graduate has an eight thousand dollar
turnaround between savings and debt
reduction in just 90 days that means
before summer break is over you're going
to feel completely different about your
money
because you'll be completely different
Financial Peace University started right
now at ramseysolutions.com FPU
ramseysolutions.com FPU Caleb's in
Austin Texas hey Caleb how are you
I'm doing well Dave how are you better
than we deserve how can we help
um I was calling because
um I'm getting ready to get married and
I have myself and my fiance we have
about 200 000 and that are close to it
uh that we are trying to figure out
what's the best Avenue for us to kind of
take good Lord who's the doctor or
lawyer
uh neither of us actually
um I uh I went to a private school to
get my bachelor's degree and what and in
Business Administration
okay
and so she got a degree in what
Communications
and the two of this is all student loan
debt or what
it's not all
at all about I want to say
probably
what's the rest
uh the rest is a a car loan that I have
how much is that and
it's a I think I was still uh 47 on it
and you just graduated from college
in 2020 yes okay so what is your income
uh my income uh this last year I grossed
117. okay what about her
42 uh after taxes I believe do you see
where the problem is Caleb
I think so I but that's why I was
calling well I'm gonna give you a hint
since you're still thinking it's the
cars
these cars are so expensive yes you got
80 000 student loans but the cars you
you could really set yourselves free if
you made some decisions with these cars
all right you have one that's 47 what's
the other one
the other one is uh her car
30 30. okay you're right then okay
you're right it's both of them
now give yourself a wedding present and
sell both these pieces of crap that are
trying to drive you into the bottom of
the ocean man good Lord when are you
supposed to get married
uh November of 2024. yeah
you're going you're going to drive away
from the church in a hoopty my man
if you're smart
is anybody paying for this what like is
is your family contributing to this
wedding or are you guys paying for it in
cash what's the plan
we are paying for it in cash okay um
and I've been saving for that right now
I'm still missing 50 Grand what's the
other 50 Grand
uh
[Applause]
I'm not I'm not sure it's more so it's
more like 180 between us I believe like
what yeah so it's like 180. I think I
got one I got 150 though
is it from her side I'm sorry yeah the
restaurant the restaurant credit cards
from her side I believe okay yeah okay
so here's the thing and I think that you
know this but in case you don't I want
to make it clear until you get married
you guys are working on this separately
so it's good that you've talked about it
it's good that you both know what's
going on right both of you looking over
each other's plan because it's getting
ready to be our plan come November but
yeah so here's what we're gonna do I
want you two to go through Financial
Peace University as our wedding gift to
you and we're going to pay for it okay
if I give it to you will you use it as
part of your pre-marriage counseling
I I don't see any reason why not
absolutely okay this is a non-week class
nine lesson class you get in a small
group that's going to guide you step by
step by step on where how to go from
where you are now which is a a hot mess
okay into uh you know really taking this
actually a good income you know you got
a hundred and hundred and fifty hundred
sixty thousand dollar household income
once you're married you should be
millionaires
within just about seven or eight years
if you'll follow what we're going to
teach you but if you go do your stupid
butt stuff that your friends are all
doing you're gonna keep these cars
because you're afraid of what somebody
thinks or cause you like the car and you
like the car more than being wealthy
someday that's what you're that's the
trade you're making so both of these
cars are insanity
they were Insanity when you bought them
and you need to get rid of them and get
cheap inexpensive cars and then lay into
this student loan debt and uh if you do
that
you know you guys could clear this 18
months after marriage you could be debt
free and if you're if you're debt free
if you don't have a payment in the world
and you're in your 20s making 160. you
can become millionaires then okay you
really can and you can drive whatever
you want later but you went and bought a
bunch of crap you couldn't afford an
expensive education that you overpaid
for and a cars that you couldn't afford
and so you've been just buying anything
you wanted because some idiot would loan
you the money
and it got you into a mess and uh so if
I were you guys if if you were my I'm
old you don't you know you're younger
than my kids so uh but if I were you if
you were my kids I would sit down and I
would love you so much that I would be
very clear with you like I am right now
because we love you and we want you to
win and uh so
and be smart about that wedding yeah
don't let that keep the wedding down
it's you know there's no correlation
between the expense of the wedding and
the success of the marriage no piece of
research between that no piece of
research between the size of the ring
and the last thing in the marriage
except possibly an inverse relationship
but the uh um oh my gosh so yeah you
guys have got some real serious
changes in the way you view the world in
order to a clean up this hot mess and B
become wealthy but I can we can show you
how to do it and I will do that as our
gift to you because we care about you
and we want you to win but dude you got
to change some stuff this is not gonna
if you just keep doing what you're doing
it's going to get bad it's not it's
you're going to have a really tough
young marriage it's gonna be very harsh
I hope she's on board for this wow he
called the crazy people on the radio he
asked for it there you go man that's
good hey hang on I'll send a pick up and
we'll get you guys signed up so Jade I
was on Neil Cavuto on Fox yesterday Neil
and I've been friends for 25 years or so
and uh of course he always pokes at me
makes fun I mean I make fun of him he's
cheap and um he's not here to defend
himself but he is cheap and um but he uh
he was like playing this clip that went
viral we had like 37 million impressions
of this clip and it was me doing what we
just did just now yes
and he's like you're so tough and I'm
like dude that is not tough I didn't
raise my voice I wasn't yelling at
anybody nobody got cussed at I mean how
is that tough where did you come from
that that's tough you I said Neil you're
pretty easily triggered what are you a
snowflake with the uh you know I mean
really that's not tough that's me
telling you the truth because I love you
yeah but Dave people think that's tough
because people think that they should be
able to well everybody just goes along
with people's stupid stuff yeah and if
you love somebody and you go along with
their stupid stuff that's not an act of
love no that's a that's an act of
cowardice enabling yeah it's enabling
and so if you want to be enabled guys
don't call this show because we're not
going to enable you we love you we're
going to tell you like it is we're gonna
we're gonna we're gonna you listen we've
all we've all done stupid stuff she had
a half million dollars in debt I went
bankrupt in my 20s I mean we've all done
stupid stuff here nobody's exempt from
it but but we're not gonna stay in it no
that's the thing and we're gonna move in
a Direction that's positive for for you
we want you to win but they do need to
go watch that clip though if they
haven't seen it it's not that come on
it's what we've done every day here on
the show I don't understand why it went
viral it's a great clip go watch it this
is the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
personality is my co-host today if you
are new to the show and based on our
rankings and ratings we know that there
are several million of you that are new
to the show you can learn some of the
lingo and figure out where you are and
what we're talking about by clicking on
the get started button at
ramsesolutions.com it's completely free
you know we'll work you in figure out
where you are so you are here and show
you what the next steps are and why and
how we're teaching this and you'll learn
stuff like baby steps and debt snowballs
and that whole process so hey thanks for
being out there we appreciate you triple
eight eight two five five two two five
Emily
is in Athens hey Emily welcome to the
Ramsey Show
[Music]
me that I owe fifty thousand dollars on
it and I want for my future
um just to have an extra income I want
to know if it would be smart to get a
um Equity the equity out of that rental
property to purchase either uh do a flip
investment or just to get another
property a rental property so I can have
that reoccurring income for the future
I wouldn't do that Emily
um if I were you I would
do you have a primary residence and if
so do you owe money on it
yes but the
part is that
the couple of years moved into it and
sell the house that we're living in now
because the house that we're in now we
purchased it because you know we have a
lot of kids and soon you know they'll be
out so what do you owe on it
on our house now that we live in we owe
200 000.
okay but if you borrow on the rental
then you're going to move into a
property that has a mortgage on it
it kind of kind of feature idea
so the what I'm in my head like uh I
don't know if I'm explaining it
correctly or not is you explained it you
said I want to take out a home equity
loan or an equity line of credit on the
rental property to buy more rental
properties but I'm going to move in the
rental property later because it's going
to be paid for no it won't you took out
a home equity loan on it and you your
whole thing was you wanted security and
all you're doing is taking on more debt
I mean so here's the thing okay Emily I
used to buy and sell real estate for a
living I've owned over 2 000 pieces of
property in my life I went bankrupt when
I was 28 years old doing the crap you're
talking about doing only I did it with
like 100 100 plus properties while
you're doing it with one so what I
figured out from that is that the
shortest distance between where you are
and wealth and security is not more
borrowed money borrowed money adds risk
and stress to your life and the chance
of failure to your life debt free moves
you the other way and when you're debt
free you don't have any payments you
have a cash flow that's unbelievably
wonderful so if I were you I would work
to get both of these current properties
paid off and then if I wanted to buy
more rentals I would save up and pay for
them that doesn't move as fast as your
plan but it also doesn't wreck the car
what your plan can do how much Equity is
in the rental
um 248
000. you want to know I'm gonna just
tell you what Jade warshaw would do I'd
want my primary mortgage paid free and
clear when are you when are you going to
sell the current house
the one that I live in now yeah you said
you're going to sell it moving to the
rental remember well that's in a couple
of years
a couple of years five or one no my kids
are still um the oldest is 15. so I'm
like I said you know once they get how
much how old is the youngest
this is long long term I would this is
what Jade would do I would get rid of
this rental take the equity and pay off
my home because you're going to be in
there the next 10 years your kid is two
yep and then when you get that house
paid off if you want to buy some rentals
or do some flips you do them well she's
going to have extra money with cash
she's still gonna have money left over
so maybe they're you know you're gonna
be there very so much faster you can get
another rental absolutely cash
absolutely that's what I would do that's
so opposite of what we what you called
about that you're not gonna do it but
that is what you should do
it's absolutely what you should do all
right let's go to uh Mary in Tampa hi
Mary how are you
hi I'm fine thank you thank you for
checking my call sure what's up
I find myself in a unique position I am
making more money than I've ever made in
my life wonderful how much money you're
making
a hundred thousand a Year yay
I'm sure send it to Dave's Cabo fund
[Laughter]
[Music]
how old are you I'm 56 years old that I
have zero saves for retirement okay
but I've been following you
I've like lowered all my expenses I've
paid off all my credit card debt
um I have six months in my uh in my
emergency room
um but I'd like to with this money make
sure I can secure my future yeah
I have a travel trailer and I own the RV
lot so so my housing expenses like
almost nothing right now
um but I would like to get into maybe
like a quad Plex or a Triplex including
one of the units and have the other two
units you know one maybe pay for it and
the other one provided a little bit uh
the income stream okay
um but
um and I don't have a vehicle right now
I'm a truck driver so I'm in my truck
all the time
um and I said I'd like to get a personal
vehicle yeah so my advice that I need
from you is number one
what do I do with this money to make
sure I don't blow it
um and um
how should I be dealing with my income
as far as my retirement gotcha who does
the collections for you on the on the
trailer lot
how do you get paid
I live in a trail you own one I I own
the RV lots
that your RV sits on right and I own the
trailer that I live in okay so if you're
on the road as a truck driver and you
had a quad Plex how are you going to
deal with Runners that's what I want to
know
um well I'm I would have my son live
with me in one of the units that he
could and he could um how old is he he's
on 31. okay and he's capable of doing
all this yes he's actually been a
handyman for an apartment community not
the handyman I'm worried about is
collecting dead gum rent
well um
I did really say Rosary metric before I
was a truck driver for like 15 years so
so you you know how to set it up and how
to get it done okay all right I would
pay cash for a piece of real estate with
the 400.
yeah and live and live in part of it and
rent out part of it I don't think your
plan's bad but I wouldn't go I wouldn't
go buy an 800 000 property I'd buy a 400
000 property
save any of this you have zero in
retirement did you say that
right do you want it right do you want
to say about two you said two to three
hundred thousand on the real estate
didn't you correct like a hundred
thousand towards my retirement fund
there you go there we go okay and buy a
car yeah and buy a car yeah I like it
you got a good plan I think you're right
on track you're being very wise let me
tell you what you're doing and you
didn't even know you were doing it that
is so wise when people get a lump sum
they tend to spend it like six times
over in their head in other words they
take 400 000 and they spend it like it's
1.6 million yeah okay and and instead of
laying out a detailed game plan and
you've got okay 200 is going to this
100's going to this we're buying a car
and we're going to have a little more in
the emergency fund and this is what
we're doing boom boom boom boom you've
already spent it real time in real
dollars on paper on purpose before you
got the money that is unbelievably wise
well done Mary
thank you you're going to be in great
shape at retirement if you keep thinking
like this
she did good everybody's into the quad
Plex ah it's all it's all over the
Internet that's all it is
well I'm proud of Mary it's a Tic Tac
real estate it is so
by the way folks single families are
much better Investments why yeah why
single families are better because when
you get ready to sell them you know who
your buyer is it's not another investor
looking for a deal it's Joe and Susie
looking for a sweet little house they're
a retail buyer single families go up
faster than quads do this is the Ramsey
Show
[Music]
hey what's up guys it's Jade look if you
like what you heard in this episode and
want to know more about getting started
on the Ramsay baby steps go to
ramsesolutions.com and click the get
started button we'll help you figure out
the best next step for you based on your
specific situation that's
ramseysolutions.com and click get
started
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show where we help people build
wealth do work that they love and create
actual and amazing relationships Jade
warshaw Ramsay personalities my co-host
today the phone number here is triple
eight eight two five five two two five
Allison starts off this hour in
Lancaster Pennsylvania hi Allison how
are you
great how are you doing better than I
deserve what's up
so I have a question about what to do if
I'm denied for a life insurance I have
kidney disease and I've tried to get
life insurance privately and through
Xander insurance and I've been denied on
both accounts you would be yeah I'm
sorry how you doing
oh it's good it's more of an autoimmune
disease that affects my kidneys I'm I've
had it for about 10 or 11 years okay
good well I'm glad you're doing okay
yeah that's a very hard one for the life
insurance actuaries they're gonna
struggle with that one are you single
I'm married okay and what is your income
I'm self-employed so it varies but it's
approximately uh 25 30 000. okay and um
your husband uh what does he earn
he earns uh he just got a promotion and
so he'll be making 85 000. cool okay and
how old are you
33. okay cool and do you all have any
money uh built up in savings or
Investments or retirement
thing up we should be finished with baby
step two in the next couple of months
good how much is in your nest egg in
your retirement from previous
about forty thousand not much okay all
right cool okay yeah okay so the purpose
of life insurance as you're probably
aware
is to replace your lost income
or something to happen to you and we
usually say 10 to 12 times your income
so 300 or 400 000 for a thirty thousand
dollar income earners what we would
normally tell you to get on a 15 or a
20-year level uh term and you can't get
that we've established that okay so what
are we going to do in the interim well
number one obviously the sooner we can
have three or four hundred thousand
dollars in your retirement accounts over
the years which you're working your baby
step to to get there I understand then
then you're self-insured at that point
if something happened to you your
husband could use that money to make
sure the family was okay and uh you know
in terms of the loss of your income does
that make sense yes the other things
that you can do are what are called
um guaranteed issue policies there that
means they don't do a medical they're
usually smaller policies like ten
thousand or Twenty Thousand or something
like that and they uh they're they're a
lot more expensive than tradition term
you can get those through like your like
mortgage life insurance that sort of
thing Dave yeah yeah you could take out
a mortgage life insurance policy on your
mortgage they paid off your mortgage in
the event of your death and that's a
guaranteed issue policy and again it's
about 5x what term is but it's still not
that bad and so like if he if you just
took care of the mortgage at your death
if you had a premature death and your
husband and kids he would be uh
financially mathematically in good shape
right
yeah so that's one place to pick it up
another is what is it what kind of a
business do you have
so I'm a court reporter and I have a
young daughter so I stay at home and I
just pretty much edit other people's
transcripts is there an association of
court reporters
yes there is yeah they probably issue
some twenty thousand dollar fifty
thousand dollar no medical required
guaranteed issue policies that are again
like that mortgage they're probably uh
five to ten times sometimes you can get
ten thousand with your checking account
at your bank that kind of a thing but I
would Pat patch together a few of those
with your mortgage life like Jade's
suggesting and then other than that I
wouldn't worry about it I just save and
invest and the faster you have a big
investment pile the faster neither one
of you need life insurance
okay does that make sense yeah it does
make sense I was just my husband has a
life
oh I see that's a bigger policy
obviously yeah um yeah but I just wasn't
able to get anything yeah like so you
got to get the guaranteed issue but
they're more expensive and or you know
continue to work your baby steps uh to
get to get to the point that you become
self-insured over time so good question
it's a great question yeah so the
guaranteed issue again it's they're
they're almost uh
including the mortgage policy life
insurance policy by the way if you're
healthy and can get insurance don't buy
mortgage life right it's five times more
expensive than the same amount of term
insurance yeah that's like recommending
it to her because she can't get life
insurance okay but the guaranteed issue
policies are more because they're
obviously taking more risk they have no
idea who's signing up exactly no medical
exam yeah and they're kind of they fall
in the gimmick category really you would
never do them unless you couldn't get
insurance otherwise yeah what would be
the purpose yeah when people get just
like it's convenient oh yeah my
Association I got one through the I got
one through the home builders you know I
got through them through my electrical
I'm an electrician you know or whatever
I don't know whatever it is and they
just they it's right there in front of
you it's it's like the Aflac crap you
know that's just kind of the same kind
of stuff it's just handy it's you know
and it's oh it's only three dollars a
week which when you add it up is like
good Lord you know that's true but yeah
that's that's what but but again this it
does have a use in the use of a
situation like Allison finds herself in
that that would be the way to go guys
there are several things you can do with
insurance that are smart
but there's a whole bunch of things you
can do with insurance that are dumb oh
yeah that that's true I think I hear a
lot of people that get caught up on like
the
like single issue Insurance like oh this
is the in case I get cancer I've got
this policy like your health insurance
doesn't have cancer yeah I don't get it
yeah yeah they're going to sell your
heart attack Insurance yeah but they
sold your cancer they might try now that
you now that you mentioned it on the air
you might have given some somebody an
idea
and you know uh accidental death in the
in the case of accidental death you get
twice as much well you're not Double
Dead
right yeah it's why do I need twice as
much if I die by accident you don't your
family needs the same amount either way
and so don't buy those gimmicky things
like that what you said I think is a is
a point that a lot of people miss the
whole purpose of it is is to replace
your income it's I think a lot of people
think well the purpose of my insurance
is to make me Rich if something if
something family Rich make the family
rich and that's not it no so if you make
fifty thousand and you got 600 000 on
you and you die your spouse takes 600
000 invested in good mutual funds if it
averages ten percent that's sixty
thousand you're now worth slightly more
dead than alive uh so don't buy too much
you'll have to sleep with them I gotta
say you better trust your spouse yeah
and so you know you but that's what it's
for and so that 600 would sit there
perpetually spitting off 60 a year to
offset the loss of the fifty thousand
dollar earned income earner and so the
family is just fine that way perpetually
so that's where the 10 to 12 times your
income comes from and most people are
underinsured and they buy the wrong
kinds of insurance and they get the
gimmicks and they get ripped off and all
their they're really spending a lot of
money they're spending more than enough
money to have the proper coverage but
don't do it hey if you want to know more
click on coverage checkup yes on our
website it's a free thing it'll run a
coverage checkup on you and say oh no
that's gimmick don't do that oh that is
good and we'll our our coverage checkup
tool will help you get dialed in on the
right kinds of insurance and as she said
check Zander Insurance for your term
insurance this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
y'all there's a lot you can't control
when it comes to health care but there
is something you should check out that
can help Christian Healthcare Ministries
chm is not Insurance it is
budget-friendly biblically based Health
cost sharing that means a community of
members helping share the burden of each
other's health care costs they help
people just like you in all 50 states so
C of chm could be right for your family
learn more today at
chministries.org budget
[Music]
yes
foreign
[Music]
personality is my co-host today
so Jade uh one of your Instagram
followers is who sent this right yes
I uh had somebody pop into my DMs as you
guys sometimes do and she was like Jade
you've got to see this and so I click
open the email and
it's a ad for
a company called lint table and so I
opened it up and I look at it and it
basically says you can't afford to for
to fund your 401k
let us do it for you
lend table we will loan you the money
to invest into your 401k up to your
match so that you can get your company
match and then we've magically solved
all your problems here
except for a couple of problems here so
just to make this clear crystal clear
you're a person you work at your job you
get a three percent match but because
you're broke you're broke you're not on
a budget you're spending all your money
you say I don't have any money to invest
in my 401k and everybody's telling me I
you know need to do it so I'm going to
go to Lin table and they're going to
loan me the money the three percent the
three percent so they give you six
thousand dollars or whatever it is you
and you invent you take that money give
it to your employer they invest it and
then they match it but here's the catch
and let me tell you it's a catch it says
once approved you can link your company
sponsored retirement account with your
bank and we will disburse the payments
you charge ten dollars a month so this
is a subscription service so you're
paying ten dollars a month 120 a year
and you sign your contract now from that
on they're they're putting the money in
and meeting the match for you now here's
the kicker and this is the one that gets
me if you leave your job so let's just
say when you leave yeah when you leave
your job now you don't just have to be
fired if you decide to move on ah you
retire you take a better job yeah you
you are on the hook for everything that
they've lended you up until that point
Dave what if you did this for like four
or five years that's a lot of money it
could end up being substantial
substantial and not only that here's
where I'm like you guys they take 20
of your earnings
twenty percent twenty percent of what
the employer match is and 20 of what it
goes up yes yeah so was it worth it so
let me get this straight this is a
credit card yeah that charges you a 120
annual fee and a 20 interest rate oh
and
it's tied to your 401k and really
screwing up your life when you leave
your company well it gets worse because
you have to write a check for the whole
thing right then and if you can't guess
what
you're gonna be cashing out the 401K or
borrowing on the 401K or screwing up the
401K there's so many stupid things here
for you to do in one possible thing and
it's all bad for you and all good for
them well I love that it says hey if you
choose to you can just repay Us by
getting a 401k withdrawal a 401k loan
you know what I'll bet you that I bet
you'll end table will issue one of their
credit cards and uh you can move the
money over to there and that's probably
only 28 percent
you know the thing that occurred to me
when I saw that I thought I wonder what
the table is I I just watched the uh you
know have you seen the John Wick movies
no Dave John Wick the evil the evil
empire in the John Wick movies is a
thing called the table the mafia
organization in the background of these
Hit Men okay it's called the table okay
and if you want to be an assassin for
the table you have to like give up a
finger or whatever okay you have to
prove your commitment right I'm tracking
the table however will turn on you
that's why they call the tables turned
that's why they call that so oh wow okay
and so the table it's and that's what I
thought of when I saw this you're going
to give up a finger yeah this is like
this is like eight digits
okay you're drawing nub back oh my gosh
at the very least they should leave you
the middle one because that's what
you're gonna that's what you want to
give them
you could just leave it with them as a
permanent sign of our affection oh man
it's terrible
oh God so you're gonna borrow at 20 of
what the employer pays you and ten
dollars and any gains and ten dollars a
month 120 a year in order to get the
employer match because you're too broke
to get the match
stuff that's What Makes You Broke
yeah stupid butt stuff makes you broke
and this fault Lin table let me help you
guys this falls under the heading of
stupid butt stuff so real stupid I think
you and I just made new friends over at
Lynn table yeah I love Jade and Dave now
well I don't like when they screw people
I don't like that I don't like products
that benefit from other people's bondage
I hate that I I hate that there's no
upside for the customers all outside for
Lindy table and and and they're they're
taking advantage of the fact that they
and you're buying into it when you do
this when when companies make products
based on the fact of you're probably not
getting more money at the end yeah
same job oh gosh who stays at the same
job you're gonna have a cash crunch
right you have a problem yeah because
you know it's like it's like borrowing
on your 401k in that sense because when
you leave your company there that's why
we tell you not to borrow on your 401k
because you get yourself in a crack man
it's bad news yeah horrible stuff domino
effect bad all right let's go to Vicky
in ah San Antonio hi Vicky welcome to
the Ramsay show
hi Dave hi Jade thanks for taking my
call sure what's up
hey I'm odd now I've worked your plan
implemented your uh books in my 40s and
paid off the house to the your the term
life insurance for my partner at the
time and we ended up splitting back in
2017 splitting the house and I had about
a hundred thousand dollars that I still
have in a savings account that I'm
wanting to figure out what to do with
and
I kind of had it for I wasn't sure what
I was going to do with it because I was
going to have to move so you like you
sold the house and or the other person
bought you out well the other person the
other person bought me out and that's
the 100k
that's the hundred thirty now it's 100
where you live now
now I'm in a new city actually with in a
house in New Braunfels area you own a
house
I do not own a house right now okay I
actually relocated to a new city I'm
living with my mom which is awesome
which that's not a problem I can afford
to get my own place but I'm trying to
figure out what I want to do if I want
to buy if I want to rent for a while so
right now I'm making I've just took a
full-time job that started back in May
I'm sorry end of March in this new town
that I love and I kind of grew up in it
so I've never worked in a place that
I've grew up in so I love the community
I'm marketing I love meeting all the
people and I think I definitely want to
stay here that was my issue I didn't
know where I wanted to really plant so
buy a house
well I I think so I just don't know how
big and there's so much exploding growth
right now and I'm thinking well shoot do
I get one of these you know condos in
one of these apartments you know I can
live in there for a while I don't need
much I don't need much I make about 82k
I got 178 in my an IRA yeah you just
want to be riding this wave up instead
of having a crash on you
absolutely and so I'm just wanting to
know how much
how much to spend I would really like
something like a two-bedroom condo
something like that where I can kind of
just get my feet wet yeah that sounds
good I would really like to start you
know reaching my full potential and
really get out of really doing paychecks
and making my own money in some way
either a small business in this area or
you know slowly just working up to
basically not working for someone else
is my goal in the long run I think you
know what you want to do I think you
know exactly what you want to do getting
a house in the area getting something
that's within your means you know are
the way we teach it is I think right up
your alley which is we don't want that
payment to be more than 25 of your
take-home pay all included on a 15-year
fixed mortgage and if you wanted it to
be you know you don't have to go all the
way up to 25 if you wanted to be more
modest you could pull it back a little
bit but you've got this hundred thousand
saved I'm assuming that you've probably
got some other money set aside if you
don't make sure you save emergency fund
inflation is debt free so I'm chunking
the hundred grand down on a nice two
bedroom condo and that it meets your
needs again no more than a fourth of
your take-home pay that's the plan and
uh yeah Jay's exactly right that's what
I would do good deal and you know that
buy something that that uh will be
fairly easy to sell later because you
you know you may decide to do something
else that's right but let's keep it
conservative so that you've got lots of
cash flow to open and start your
business as well this is the Ramsay show
foreign
[Music]
a home is one of the biggest decisions
of your life you need a partner like
Churchill Mortgage Churchill is one of
the highest rated lenders in the country
and their Ramsay trusted because they do
what's right for you Churchill works
with you to build a mortgage the Ramsay
way one that doesn't bust your budget
sets you up for financial success and
helps you get out of debt faster go to
churchillmortgage.com today and get
started
[Music]
yeah
Jade warshaw Ramsey personality is my
co-host today thank you for joining us
America open phones at triple eight
eight two five five two two five if you
missed it earlier this week we announced
that we're taking smart conference
weekend on the road Chicago Illinois
we're headed your way this fall
September 15 and 16. me Rachel Cruz
George Campbell Dr John deloney Ken
Coleman and Jade warshaw for two
action-packed days of life-changing
content actually it's Friday night all
day Saturday to help you be successful
in every area of your life with your
money your career your mental health and
your relationships we've got a lot
planned great speakers great teachers
through the whole time and a live vaping
of smart money Happy Hour podcast with
George and Rachel and there's other
surprises throughout the weekend this is
your chance to join thousands of
like-minded people and get smarter and
you get to meet Rachel George John Ken
Jade in person take pictures with him
we're headed to Chicago uh now we've got
VIP VIP Platinum all kinds of special
experiences and the tickets start for
the general admission at just 79 and
they go up from there depending on how
involved and plugged in you want to be
we've got I think 60 tickets for a
dinner after the event with all of the
Ramsey personalities with only 60 people
so now that ticket is not 79 I'll just
tell you so check it out
ramsesolutions.com
events Gia is it Gia or Gia
Gia Gia
yep okay Grand Island Nebraska hi Gia
how are you
I'm better than I deserve how are you
better than I deserve what's up
all right so I've got a question my
husband and I have been working your
plan and we're actually coming in a
couple weeks to do our debt free screen
good my question is
um right now my husband and I apparently
are not normal and we only have one
debit card with both of our names on it
so we're trying to decide where we want
to get our next
debit card so I'm trying to decide is it
better to go with a small Federal Credit
Union around us or would it be better to
go with like a bigger corporation that
would have a better
um interest rate for the savings because
my thought process was to move emergency
savings into one of their savings
accounts but I would still have access
to with the debit card and it would be
hooked together
but and then allow it to be able to gain
interest but I'm not sure which is
better no I wouldn't have uh debit card
connected to your emergency fund
okay that's asking for trouble
you know you'll find a couch on sale
that'll be an emergency mm-hmm
fair enough so would you still have a
second yes debit card because I've just
had it where yeah you know it's a stupid
thing
exactly if it gets shut down you can't
pay for dinner or something you're you
know you don't have enough cash in your
pocket yeah I I have several uh debit
cards and um I actually have um multiple
cards with One Bank different accounts
and then I've got another bank that we
also have cards with so um so that I'm
not stuck I I carry two in my wallet but
I have
[Music]
um
in one of those on the business and one
in our case and one on my personal uh
and then
I have more you know in uh you know in
my briefcase so to speak and uh if I
need something for something else I've
got access that way but no I don't do
any business with large corporate Banks
I work with regional Banks and local
credit unions
okay so it would just you can even get
it for like a different like just like a
different account but at the same like
Federal Credit Union yourself drop a
thousand bucks into a checking account
over somewhere it's not how much
interest it earns that doesn't really
matter if this is just more as a safety
net
I'm with that that makes that makes
perfect sense hey thanks for the call
appreciate you joining us so here's the
thing uh credit cards and debit cards
reminder to everyone they run on uh in
most places they run on the same
algorithm for fraud yeah so uh if you're
if your credit card's gonna be shut down
for because it got some kind of a fraud
notification or something that that woke
the computer up and said oh this one's
about something's going on here uh then
then your credit card will be shut down
same thing so you can be if you only had
one credit card or One debit card you
can be stranded these days that's true
so she she was saying they were
operating off of One debit card for that
for the family that's yeah for the whole
family I mean Sharon and I both have a
debit card on the same account that's
the same thing yeah that's what we have
in a sense and the numbers are different
though so yeah I think that's what she
meant if mine was messed up I might be
able to get it home you know what I'm
saying yeah you could issue another one
to your spouse yeah and that would give
you if you're together yeah and you had
a problem that would give you because
we've done that well I uh messed up and
left my card in the pocket when it went
through the washer and it's bent and
half the time it doesn't work so half
the time I'm like Sam let me use your
debit card it's the same account you
know you're in order I can date that you
know I'm working I got work to do I
can't I can't be
I don't have time for this stuff I don't
have time for this stuff
Deborah's in Philadelphia hi Deborah
welcome to the Ramsey Show
hi thanks for taking my call sure what's
up
I would like to help my son get into a
single family home and I'm not sure the
best way to go about it
suppose you need your help
um he doesn't qualify for much of a
mortgage he's currently renting a house
with a roommate
um my son recently got engaged and he
and his fiance would like to live
together
unfortunately I'm over in New Jersey and
Lance here are just crazy they'll never
get ahead if they got a rent and
whatever you're not going to like me or
me
you don't need to do you don't need to
do this
no why because you're not helping him
you're enabling him
he hasn't got his crap together enough
to go buy a house you're going to get
him into a house and it's going to be a
curse not a blessing because he hasn't
got his crap together to get into aisles
well in which way do you say it's going
to be it's broke you said pay the bill
the reason they won't give him a loans
because they know he isn't going to pay
the bill and then you get him into the
house and he doesn't pay the bill why
because he can't pay the bill
well I kind of look at it as
part of this inheritance now you're
gonna pay because you're gonna give him
a house for free
I don't know about that but then you're
going to sign him up for something he
can't do
that's not a blessing Deborah well how
about if I were to buy the house and he
rented it for me how about your grown
son becomes a man
okay that's what you should do he needs
to be on his own he needs to stand up
he's going to get married to this girl
they need to sit up and have a life
instead of mommy taking care of him
really this is not good for him Deborah
it's not good for him I know you're the
sweetest lady on the planet I'm being
mean to you but you're just trying to be
helpful to your little boy but I got to
tell you one of the things I had to do
with my wife when we were Raising a Son
was to let him be a man let him it's a
Sharon no yes you can't do you got to
young people have to have dignity yes
and she owes it not only to him but this
is the side I see to the girl that he's
dating because she needs to see what
kind of man this is going to be and if
mommy is swooping in and paying all the
bills so they can live together and
she's never gonna see
who he truly is he's disqualified as a
proper husband at that point hey guys
mom and moms and dads you know love your
children enough to let them do hard
things called life like I told you
Deborah I told you at the front of this
you weren't gonna like me and you're not
gonna do it you're gonna go in there and
interfere and screw this up because you
ain't gonna listen to a thing I said but
the the deal is that moms and dads if
you will let your kids find their way
coach them
cheer for them if they're in a really
hard pinch be a safety net but don't
interfere we're seeing data right now
that 25 percent of Millennials their
parents are paying for their housing in
one way or another
let me just tell you moms and dads not
good not good for your little millennial
they are much better off to face some
calluses some stress some hard times
make some hard choices stand up and
square their shoulders and be a man be a
woman instead of a child it's not good
for them are they not good for
themselves they're not good for their
spouses they're not good for their
employers because Mommy and Daddy swoop
in and take care of everything bad plan
America bad plan so Deborah we love you
you're sweet you love your little boy
but he's not a little boy anymore
this is the Ramsey chef
[Music]
foreign
personality is my co-host today I'm Dave
Ramsey your host this is the Ramsey Show
Dan is next in Sarasota Florida hi Dan
how are you
I'm good Dave thank you for taking my
call my pleasure sir a question I have a
question about long-term
health care we purchased it in 2009 and
this last couple of weeks ago we saw
that they were going to raise the price
up to like 75 over the next three years
my question is is there another
alternative or what do you think about
doing that
well my guess is you have three years of
coverage would that be right
uh yes yes that's correct and what are
they charging what are they charging
five or something like I'm sorry uh uh
right now we're paying 3 10 a month for
two of us and my mine is 158 and my wife
says 151 she's a lot younger than I am
so so it's uh 3 700 a year what uh what
are they going to take it to
uh probably like 6 200 a year in one
year wow no in three years oh 25 to 30
every year
okay and that's really different than
what they did in the past so okay all
right have you looked at
um nursing home providers in your area
we have some yes okay I'd go shop a
couple of them I think you're going to
find 80 to 100 000 a year is your
exposure
the average nursing home stay in America
is two and a half years
if you go past three years you're
self-insured anyway
right so all you've got is basically 250
000 worth of insurance
that's what you've got so how much money
do y'all have
oh oh
they have enough uh plenty put aside
um no I mean is your net worth five
million dollars or a million dollars oh
no no no no no no no more like a million
more like a million all right so 75
percent of the ladies that outlive their
husbands
so the normal statistical scenario is
that you go into the nursing home you
spend 250 300 000 and she's left with
what's left
that's the normal scenario
statistically okay now some people live
longer in nursing homes
truthfully the vast majority don't make
it two years once you go in
okay statistically it's not saying
nursing homes are killing people but
that's not the point okay now the other
thing that's an option is
um
you could just decide to self-insure
that was what I was going to ask how old
are you guys Dan
well I'm 77 and my wife is a young 72.
okay so if um
one of you required care
I also would in addition to pricing a
nursing home I would price what it would
take to get 24-hour care in the home
right you probably can do that for
eighty thousand dollars
right that's what you're going to spend
on the nursing home and then you've just
got to decide do I want to spend
3700 4300
five thousand six thousand against a two
hundred and fifty thousand dollar
exposure
because that's your average exposure
right yeah you're not going to get any
more out of this
policy than that that's the most because
it covers three years and if you said
you know if you said 80 000 bucks that's
240 000 so
um you know we're right around a quarter
million dollars and so my guess is that
if something happened to you and you
burn through a quarter of a million your
wife would be okay on the 750. oh by the
way if it happens seven years from now
you're probably gonna have two million
dollars to work with yes that's what I'm
because your money's invested well your
money's invested right I hope it's
invested yeah what portion of that yes
what portion of that net worth is
is invested in the stock market
uh
uh none of it I have it all in um in a
savings account but I'm getting like
three three and a half percent did you
say that you have a million dollars in a
savings account
no I said I'm worth a million dollars my
house is worth more than that what
portion of that is in the savings
they're in their 70s he's doing that for
safety let's stay on yeah you're you're
you're the thing I mean I we would I'm
just slightly younger than you and I
would probably have some of that still
invested that's what Jade's having a
hemorrhage about I am I'm hemorrhaging
but there's 72 and 77 so okay okay uh
you know that's okay but the point being
it's not going to double in seven years
I'm wrong because it's not it's not
invested it's gonna double in
uh 20 years so you're not gonna double
okay so uh
but it will grow if your wife is
comfortable
with it she can live
off of seven hundred thousand dollars
left over after you spend 300 on you
then you can drop these policies but
until then you carry them if I'm in your
shoes it's kind of on the bubble I'm
probably going to keep them a couple
more years
um because a trade of three grand for a
potential 300 Grand or 250 Grand uh
exposure and make sure that your policy
covers in-home care as well and again
I'm recommending that I'm not against
nursing homes I don't think they do that
they all do a bad job some of them do
but some of everybody does a bad job so
um but the nursing home industry is not
evil they do a good job they they have a
tough job but in our case the Ramses
we've got plenty of money to do either
one we simply will just hire in home
care we can afford it yeah and uh we'll
just staff it up and so when you reach
the point of being self-insured that's
what a lot of people are choosing to do
because of quality of life uh and and so
forth but the thing you've got to swear
you're going to do is not leave all the
Care on the spouse right get some people
in there to help carry the weight of the
process in some cases literally carry
the weight of the process so um yeah
that's
but that that's what you can look at and
so long-term care insurance if you have
less than a million dollars and you are
60 years old as far as I'm concerned
it's mandatory
you should get long-term care insurance
if you've got north of a million dollars
and you are a million like I said he's
on the bubble and you want to uh talk
about self-insuring in either case look
at In-Home Care coverage in your
long-term care policy and look at
in-home care as a possibility if you're
self-insuring uh again because you you
know I don't know there's something
about the nursing home that people like
oh it's I took care of that now well no
you really haven't it's there's still a
lot of stuff going on that's right
um but yeah the long-term care insurance
at 60 years old I would not buy it
before you're 60. the probability of
using it before your 60s less than one
percent I would not buy it for that but
once you're 60 I would and Dan's been
wise I think two have bought this yeah
I'm probably keeping it if I'm him and
one of the reason I'm going to say that
is he's super conservative
he's not invested yeah I know that
that's what threw me off that's what I
had a slight connection over
you did I did that's true I mean yeah
you need to have uh because if you could
be let's say you got
300 000 bucks
um is sitting in the bank at three
percent and it could be making 12 in a
good mutual fund
um that's a thirty thousand dollar swing
yeah that's what that is and so a year
that's 2500 a month swing that would pay
almost for the whole thing I mean that's
it takes us along not that it would pay
for the more than pay for the uh
the policy that's for sure yeah my
thought was just on on how that net
worth was broken up because of you know
if the majority of that is sitting in
your home and but you're you know you're
not going anywhere I feel like there's a
couple of things that you would
definitely want to play out play that
scenario out if you chose to self-insure
yeah if it's an 800 000 home and 200 000
in mutual you can't do that you can't
you can't you've got to keep the policy
yeah you're exactly right so the mix
would matter yeah and that's what I was
trying to get to with Dan but um
you know yeah something tells me he's
it's probably kind of equal he's
probably got a Sarasota he's probably
got
he didn't say but maybe 500 in his house
and then yeah hopefully that's the mix
the way it is yeah
yeah so uh with you being conservative
Dan I'm going to tell you probably keep
it
if you had two million I would tell you
to probably self-insure yeah yeah it's a
big difference that'd be the difference
so you did a good job though you're
retiring a millionaire you did you did
great you're taking care of your family
the whole process is excellent very very
well done love it
that puts us out of the Ramsey Show in
the books
[Music]
hey what's up guys it's Jay if you love
the show and want a deeper dive on your
money Journey we have a Weekly
Newsletter that gives you trending and
helpful articles and tips on following
the Ramsay way just go to
ramsesolutions.com today to sign up for
our newsletter again that's
ramsesolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]
thank you
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show where we help people build
wealth do work that they love and create
actual amazing relationships Jade
warshaw Ramsay personality is my co-host
today open phones at triple eight eight
two five five two two five starting off
this hour's Jill in Dallas hi Jill
welcome to the Ramsay show
[Music]
good after I'm
I mean thank you so much for your time
well we're honored how can we help
I have an investment question please I
value your opinion very much
um we have a question about paying off a
reverse mortgage for my father-in-law
my husband and I make between 180 and
200 000 a year we have no debt we have
about 1.2 in our
um
retirement accounts we own our house and
we also own two other houses wow very
good so your net worth is north of 4
million
uh but probably between two and three
the one of the houses is is pretty small
um that's a story in itself but anyway
um our father my husband's father
um has a reverse mortgage
um and we would like to pay it off
the um the interest rate seems to be
quite really dominant yeah yes and in
another six or seven years the interest
will have eaten up the complete value of
the home
um we would I just want to know from
your perspective
we were considering taking out the money
they there's 160 out on the house we
were considering withdrawing it my
husband is uh 59 and a half we were
considering withdrawing it and making it
like an investment since real estate
does appreciate I realized that it would
his father is 89 and so this could be
tied up for 10 plus years that long-term
Investments usually are just that long
term
um so I just from your perspective would
really value your opinion in uh what
what do you think of this what what
pitfalls do you see it's very sad that
your father-in-law is 89 and he's got
himself in a position with his rip-off
reverse mortgages to being a pinch I'm
so sorry the great news is you guys are
in great shape and you're able to do
this so does your husband have siblings
jazz
um
plus the same gain that we had made on
our 401k and not that be ours because
you can't take the money out and not
make something on it because what is the
mouse currently worth
the house is worth about 330. okay
um and none of the other siblings are in
a position to help
that's one of the houses we own so he is
very ill and needed to be inside our
county line so that the county could
cover its health care so okay so uh no
one's going to object to anything here
then I I don't think so his dad would
like to keep it a secret until after
he's gone and let it be a surprise I
think that's a bad idea that's how
everybody gets that's how people spend
the rest of their lives pissed off nope
we're going to tell everybody in the
family what's going on and here's what
we're gonna do yeah indeed the house to
you guys yes sir and you all just pay it
off and it's your house
and then you pay for the insurance and
you pay for the taxes you pay for the
maintenance and Dad gets to live there
for life
or as long as he as long as he can stay
in the house that is anyway not like
yeah if he's able to if he has to be
cared for in some other way then that'd
be different but yeah just just you know
we'll get you out dad um but go ahead
and just date it to us now uh and that's
our return and uh we're and we're also
gonna have to invest more because we're
gonna have to cover the maintenance and
we're gonna have to cover the taxes and
insurance for you to live there for free
as long as you're able to live in the
house
yes sir and that's a fair that's a fair
deal financially it's also a very kind
thing for you all to do and you're in a
position to do it and you'll you'll be
okay financially you're not stupid but
I'm not doing this and keep it a secret
secrets are ugly and stuff like this
okay all right I want to I don't want to
cause a problem
okay well then we won't we won't keep it
a secret yeah they need to they they
it's just fair okay and if anybody wants
if anybody has a better plan we all can
do it but if you're if you don't have a
better plan you don't have the money
we're standing here with the money we
can do this but I don't want to I don't
want some uh character in the family to
be yelling later oh Jill took advantage
of Grandpa yeah you know and it has to
be the D the house has to be deeded up
front it can't be they will give them
the money to pay the house off and then
he Wills us the house like it can't be
that no no you get the house in your
name now now okay and we were taking the
money out of our 401k to pay it off yeah
I mean we've got plenty in there and
we've still got another many years to
still you don't have enough in a side
investment account that's not 401k to do
it do you
uh no we've only got about 50 in another
account we don't have enough to pay it
off yeah you're gonna pay taxes so it's
gonna cost you 200 Grand to get this out
yeah particular 160 and so yeah I'm
still doing it though it's why you work
you're able to take care of dad but I'm
not going to have anybody objecting to
this and we're gonna and we're gonna
control the variables because he
obviously has
um
we know that he doesn't always make good
decisions because he made the decision
to put a reverse mortgage on there
and so I can't leave the house in his
name hoping he's going to make good
decisions no we're going to take care of
this so that we can take care of him
okay all right I just want to do the
right thing that's all I don't know you
don't want to hurt no one's feelings
well you have such a good heart you do
and hopefully everyone will see the good
in this and there won't be a a relative
that objects but if there is at least
they'll know it on the front end and we
can just go this is what we're doing and
unless you've got a better plan to take
care of him he's otherwise going to end
up losing his house so what do you
people want to do here yeah these
reverse mortgages are from the pit of
Hell they're horrible terrible
absolutely horrible who High interest
rates High fees and what's weird is of
course the reverses they pay for those
of you don't know how it works they're
paying the old man payments until it
gets to 65 percent loan to value when it
gets to 65 loan to value they stop the
payments
and now they just add interest to the 65
until it eats up the entire value and
then they foreclose that's so sad or if
he doesn't keep up the taxes and
insurance even after they stop the
payments that throws it into fault and
they foreclose so regular home mortgages
have about a two to a three percent
foreclosure rate uh reverse mortgages
have a 15
foreclosure rate just to get that so I'm
not kidding when I say this is a rip-off
yeah I mean and there's you know and and
they're sold on television on ads by
washed up actors between between the
walk-in bathtubs I saw Joe
my name is Montel Jordan yeah
yeah
my greatest fear in life is I live long
enough
to do one of those ads
you would never
you're right I would never
I'm not that desperate to be in front of
a camera
at the Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
Jade warshaw Ramsey personality is my
co-host today thank you for joining us
America the phone number here is triple
eight eight two five five two two five
whole bunch of your brand new we
appreciate that we're glad you're here
you can help us out if you would whether
you're old-timer or whether you're brand
new we need the help you can do three
things to help us move this show out and
help America and serve America by
telling them the truth because we love
them
and uh that's simply this share of the
show tell people about it click the
share link if you're on a podcast or
YouTube or something like that click the
share link share the link however you
want to do it I don't care but pass this
along to your friends you can subscribe
or follow if you're on a podcast and you
can leave us a five-star review if
you're a podcast or YouTube say
something nice like five stars because
mama said if you ain't anything nice to
say don't say anything at all just move
along and now we're I think we're number
11 podcast on Apple's ranking it comes
and goes uh in the entire world of
podcasts which is some two or three
million podcasts that are out there
that's not a nuanced uh category that's
of all of them and so thank you guys we
appreciate that we have not spent 300
million dollars on marketing this year
instead you guys are just telling us You
Like It by telling each other about it
so thank you thank you thank you Katrina
is in Chicago hi Katrina welcome to the
ram show
better than we deserve what's up
I have I own a condo in Chicago
and I am looking to buy a second home in
Nashville Tennessee one and what I'm
wondering is why because
my boyfriend got transferred to
Nashville and then I've been doing long
distance and so now we want to
to live in the same city
to to figure out if we're going to
marriage so you're going to move from
Chicago to Nashville
I could be
malt but in the meantime I had to come
in
I'm supposed to be around 60 so I'm
I'm still doing that by going to
Nashville but it's a little painful
so you want a second home in Tennessee
is your current home in Chicago paid for
it is
wow okay so I don't have any yet
currently okay and I really don't want
to get any because you know how this
works yeah I do know how it works well
my question is why do you feel that you
would have to just hypothetically why do
you feel that you would have to buy a
home so once you're just running a party
for six months
the brand is so expensive but even if
this wasn't sure if there was no
boyfriend or anything like that I we
would we would never say to just walk in
and up and buy a house you would just
want to get a feel of the area figure
out what what life happens getting a
feel of the area in the last I've been
doing this for a year and a half like
going back and forth how old are you
I'm 46. what do you make
I make 183 and then a a bonus that's
about a hundred how long how long you
been dating boyfriend
since we're pandemic love
[Laughter]
pandemic love that's the pain that came
out of it that's much better than puppy
love I'm just saying
but it's funny here's the thing I'm
slightly well no I'm robbing the cradle
a bit he's much younger I didn't know
that but it is what it is doesn't matter
so that's another reason why I
like I have that's just another reason
why that's just another reason we think
you're awesome right there so okay
um okay so the uh but here's the deal
you're making a permanent real estate
decision in a temporary situation that's
a bad move this is a situation where you
rent until the permanent shakes out
there's two issues on the permanent when
the relationship goes from boyfriend to
husband and when the job allows you to
move now we have permanent
then we buy as a matter of fact then we
buy you and him because you're married
until then uh you know you're you're
doing this Gypsy thing back and forth
corporate Gypsy thing and remote semi
and long distance uh love affair and all
this and all of that just screams rent
ing this out long term okay you got the
paid for house in Chicago let's say you
come to Tennessee you rent for a while
you got you know your work thing works
out you get engaged you decide to get
married you can sell the Chicago house
and you can probably end up buying
whatever house you get here in Tennessee
in cash
as opposed to trying to do you see what
I'm saying those screams rent for six
months yeah long term it's better to do
it to do it this way okay but then if I
hear what you're saying but then can I
ask yeah my question was going to be
when I buy that place I have cash in
three different places and I'm wondering
okay yeah but you're gonna sell a place
in Chicago yeah you got to sell the
place in Chicago the end of the story if
it goes like you think unless I'm
missing something
is you're married and live in Nashville
right yeah yeah that's the end of the
story so you're going to sell the place
in Chicago and you've got cash and
you've got him hopefully he's worth
something we didn't even ask about that
please please tell us it's good Katrina
it's good he's just fun you know he's
he's more puffy in his you know how
weird is this guy I don't mean that but
like compared to like there's a lot of
earning potential between 32 and 46.
okay okay all right I see you Katrina I
see you out here all right here hey yeah
just uh what's Happening Here is
um this is an exciting Adventure in your
life and don't confuse that with real
estate
real estates when things are stable and
boring and you pay cash so I would not
buy right now because if you buy you're
going to end up selling what you buy
and doing something different when this
all settles you're going to end up doing
you're saying we want to set up our
lives and it's not in this house or not
in this condo and so it's just it just
bothers you because you're cheap to rent
because you feel like you're wasting
money but rent when it's in a proper
scenario and this is a proper scenario
is called paying for patience and look
if you move all the way down to
Tennessee your boy better put a ring on
it that's all I'm saying if you're
making this type of transition he needs
to come through and I hope that he does
for you yeah Mama Jade with relationship
advice there we go right there ding ding
I love it good stuff Stacy's in
Bakersfield California hi Stacy welcome
to the Ramsay show
oh thank you for having me sure what's
up
well um I listened to your podcast the
way home from a trip and I was really uh
you pulled me in
um I'm very newly divorced I've never
operated on a budget at all
um I have some debt in this new single
life of mine and I have a little bit of
money in a brokerage account and how
much debt and how much in the brokerage
account
only 22 000 I have about 38
000 in debt half of it is a medical bill
and the other half is credit cards
and it really just need some direction
and help what do you make
I make um well I gross about 107 and
this year I'm going to get a five
percent though but 113 a year
no kids right right all right you know
if I were you I would probably do that I
you know if I had money set aside that
was not retirement I'd probably
pull some from it to pay debt especially
if it's single stocks yeah I'm gonna
cash it all in and clear the debt and
because we're going to get you on the
debt snowball we're going to put you on
a budget and a budget's not a beans and
rice thing it may be for a little while
do you get some of these bills cleaned
up yeah but then after that it's just
you telling your money what to do and
giving you confidence in this new stage
of life for handling your own money and
I also want you to download every dollar
that's the budgeting app that we use
here and it's great it's going to help
it's going to help anybody who's never
budgeted before learn how to do it
because it's not just an app where you
put the numbers in it's teaching you and
there's teachings that are built into
the app that help you throughout this so
that's what I would do and I'm excited
that you're on this journey I think that
it's exciting that you're finally
getting in control of your money and
that starts with you budgeting it starts
with you getting out of debt and uh make
sure before you do all of this that you
put aside a thousand dollars for
emergencies because you need that first
things first for your starter beginner
emergency fund so every dollar will do
that and uh I'll tell you what let's
just go ahead since you're starting a
new phase of Life put you into Financial
Peace University uh that's a nine week
class a nine lesson class on how to
handle money and give you your
confidence in this area and we'll help
you do it we're gonna do it all for free
it's just our gift to you help you start
fresh
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
Jade warshaw Ramsay personality is my
co-host today I'm Dave Ramsey your host
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five Nicole in
Syracuse New York hi Nicole how are you
[Music]
great what's up
one of our cars well our only car with a
huge nine thousand dollar payment to
eliminate that debt it took a lot of
strong arming my husband to let go of
that money to pay it off but we did so
last year we sold his car to get out of
that debt and save money since he's able
to walk to both his jobs
uh it's worked for us for almost a year
my husband has a full-time job for 22 an
hour and part-time with 17 an hour and I
get 16 an hour for my part-time job we
take home about 4 530 a month
uh so my husband is looking for a better
job that would pay him
about 25 to 28 an hour
if he gets this job we would have to
come up with at least 7 000
quick to get a new car or a used car and
we're where did 7 000 come from
so we've been working with a car broker
Auto Broker and um that's like around
the number that we are have been looking
for
um but yeah if uh if he gets that then
you know we can get down to one job and
I won't be going crazy with the kids at
home all day alone so my question is is
it worth it for him to go for that job
that cost a little I mean pays him a
little bit more or should we just
continue what we're doing
yeah
so let me get this straight I I'm I want
to make sure I'm tracking with you
you're you're saying that if your
husband gets this other job it's going
to require you to get another vehicle
and you want to know is it is his pay
increase worth that cost
yeah so he because he works a job and a
half and if he gets this other job he
could eliminate the other two jobs okay
um yeah and then we would actually see
each other once in a while how would you
pay for it how would you how would you
pay for that
the new car um that's the thing like we
don't know how we would come up with
because we just did that big payment on
the that car and I took a lot of
convincing to get him to do that
um and do you have to pay I mean you
don't have to pay seven thousand having
to convince him doesn't enter into this
discussion
the only thing that enters into the
discussion is what makes sense for your
family he shouldn't need convincing on
that he should just want to do it you
should just want to do it what's best
for your family I'm very cautious yeah
you don't have seven thousand dollars
right no right you can't buy a seven
thousand dollar car then what how much
could you scrape together to get to make
this happen
I think in like if he got hired after
the hiring process and he got hired
within like two months we might be able
to get five thousand all right together
so yeah well but you're starting now
you're part starting to put aside now
because you know that this is on the
horizon so he wouldn't wait until you
know don't wait until the cards are on
the table start start putting aside now
so that he has it okay let's just be
real clear your household income if I
understood you correctly if he takes
this job does not go up
he just is going to be working less
because he's making more at the new job
your quality of life goes up so the
numbers don't change at your house when
he gets the new job am I right
correct okay that's what I thought I
understood so Jade is exactly right then
you can save up starting right now
and buy a two thousand dollar car or a
four thousand dollar car or a three
thousand dollar car whatever cash you
can scrape together there's no magic to
seven the only magic seven is you don't
have it so that's not so you can't do it
great right because you're not gonna
listen if you continually figure out a
way to rationalize borrowing money
you're going to borrow money the rest of
your life and just be normal broke
people
you got to stop that you have to draw a
line to send debt is not an option now
what do we do
we want a better life he wants this
better job I'm with you on both of those
things got no issue with that now how do
we get started over there or how do we
scrape up some money when do you think
he's going to hear on this job
uh he's got an interview on Thursday so
is it a one and done interview or is it
a six-week interview process
well he's had an interview for this job
before and then he applied he keeps
applying to the same job over and over
again
um same company I mean but um so why is
he was he going to get it this time
I don't know what kind of hey what kind
of job what what is it what is it that
he's interviewing for
uh grocery store manager for Aldi is
there any other chains that he can be
interviewing for the same position why
has it got to be the same Aldi can he
look at Publix can he look at Kroger
Whatever It Is by you HyVee whatever the
grocery store chains are is he just
putting all his chips in one bag or can
he
you know I'm just trying to get a beat
on what's really going on
right yeah I guess we were uh just kind
of like I think he's putting out a lot
of feelers for different jobs but that's
the one that um that's the one he wants
yeah I want to be serious again I'm not
trying to be sarcastic or mean he's
applied for this job multiple times and
has not gotten it why is it now you're
more sure what what evidence do you have
[Music]
okay so let's stop then you're tired
of him working all the time and so
you're trying to wish this into
existence and somehow figure out a way
to buy a car that you don't need to be
buying until this all goes down
you're just tired you're you've been
fighting this baby step two stuff and
your tank is starting to get empty am I
wrong
correct all right I hope your wish comes
true I hope he gets this and you all get
a better quality of life making the same
amount of dollars how much debt do you
all have left
um we have
um home equity loan for about 10 000 and
then
um he has his student loans with her on
pause for thirty nine thousand and then
our house we have 61 000. yeah well the
third so baby step two is the home
equity loan and the student loans so you
got 49 000 left and your household
income total in a year is what
Brown
um
or taxes Route 50
I have a question for you and I don't
want to dig the hole deeper are you guys
working towards your long-term play
for careers
um I'm kind of dislike working part-time
jobs like I don't yeah because it kind
of sounds like
a long time play okay
his jobs are like uh grocery store
managers like he doesn't really have a
long time play either I want you guys
okay in the break let's pick up and
let's get you guys paycheck to purpose
let's do the career assessment all that
stuff because I feel like the Ken coma
materials you guys need to get the
career thing around yeah because that's
what's going to give you grabbing it
little things and you got this one thing
this one Aldi store this one managership
what Jade was telling you earlier we
want to
um we want to help we want you to earn
more for your sake and that's going to
make this whole thing get better and go
faster I hope he gets this one but if he
doesn't we need a better plan and uh
because you still got at your current
income you've still got two years to go
that's maybe step two in your snowball
it's gonna you you're tired and you're
already tired so
I do think you all need to get a car I
think the one car is adding to the
family stress yeah even not counting
this job stuff is that right
correct yeah so um yeah we need to do
that and I want him not to have to be
coerced into these things I want him to
be leading into these things with you
the two of you holding hands and walking
towards the light right and doing this
together that's going to make that's
going to lower the stress for both of
you as well because he's not giving up
his life he's living his life
uh it's through and with his family
that's what he chose and that's what
he's doing because he's a good man but
it's not like your mommy and telling a
little boy he can't have candy that's
right that's not what's going on so this
is a man who's leaning in good for him
and he's he he's working with his wife
and we're fighting for a better future
together as two grown-ups and that's how
it should be and so you got a good guy
there he's a good guy yeah you probably
you guys probably do need to budget in a
car into your debt snowball and let's
start working on the career stuff too so
um but hang on we'll have Austin pick up
we'll get you paycheck to purpose book
for him and uh and for you by Ken
Coleman and the get clear assessment to
help you figure out what kind of careers
to aim at where there's serious money
that can be taken off the table I'd love
to see you all double your income the
next five years Yep this is the Ramsay
show
[Music]
thank you
our scripture today Proverbs 14 23 there
is profit and hard work
but mere talk leads to poverty
Stephen King says Talent is cheaper than
table salt what separates The Talented
individual from the successful one is a
lot of hard work
Jade warshaw Ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
Stephen is up next in Cookeville
Tennessee hi Stephen welcome to the
Ramsey Show
hi thanks for having me on sure how can
we help
essentially uh all my life I've really
been earning below the poverty line
um you know living in a low income area
it's it's kind of kind of goes with with
the the lifestyle I guess uh but with
recent years of of people not wanting to
work and uh
you know and that tailored with you know
a lot of a lot of uh houses and and
mortgages going up and and everything I
I don't I simultaneously see a a
opportunity to make a lot more money
which I don't really know how to do as
well as having the dread of not being
able to afford a home within the next 10
years uh so it's kind of like a duality
sort of thing and I'm wondering uh what
would your advice be for trying to jump
on that opportunity to to earn as much
income as possible uh for for somebody's
in my situation
what do you want to do
well uh I've always been enamored with
with film and in the art of it uh I I
did go to film school about 10 years ago
didn't get to finish it because of uh
how much I didn't make enough money I'm
currently in a uh an acting class right
now but I've always wanted to know I've
always wanted to be able to have
something to fall back on but uh yeah
the thing the thing with the Arts is the
thing with the Arts is you've got to
make money until you make money
basically is the way that works
um
you know when it when whenever I hear
people talk like this where it's like
I've been I'm below the poverty line I'm
kind of caught up into this I think
you've gotta drill down and instead of
looking at all those outward reasons why
just look at your specific situation why
are you not
getting up and finding work that's
paying more what is it that's keeping
you from that is it that you don't know
what you want to do is it that you don't
know how to what the actual next step is
like what are you need to start asking
yourself those questions because that's
what's going to give you the next step
forward so you said you went to school
for acting you tried the acting thing I
mean I would want to drill down more on
that and find out what happened but in
the meantime what kept you from doing
other work
well I I I'm currently in an acting
class it's thankfully it's pretty cheap
I can I can at least afford that
um and I I get get that done in August
and uh but it's from what I can tell
it's uh because I I've I do I've done a
lot of job hunting and it seems to be an
educational boundary that I've not been
able to crack
what do you do now
uh currently I'm in security for a a uh
entertainment venue
I've got about three three years worth
of uh experience in security and what
are you earning
um after taxes a little over 30k a year
and it's full time
yes ma'am okay that's not the poverty
level you know that
oh yeah it's lower it's lower income but
it's not the poverty level oh okay I
mean poverty level for a single guy in
Cookeville would be fifteen thousand for
a while I I commute to Nashville too so
do you have any debt why do you commute
to Nashville for a thirty thousand
dollar job
uh it's just not I've never not been
able to find much in Cookeville
um in terms of uh yeah yeah it's a
two-hour Drive each way yeah where where
I live it's I'm kind of I kind of uh
have has the ability to afford
my friend Henry Cloud says that what we
need to do is lay in front of ourselves
when we're setting goals when we want to
move when we want to level up
we we say okay here's what I want to be
doing and that's our desired future and
then once we have the desired future
figured out then we have to say Okay
what must be true about me about my life
about my education about my location
that is not true now in order for me to
have my desired future now you ask us
about a desired future that makes more
money than you make today we've had an
exploratory conversation around that all
right and so uh number one there's not
going to be acting jobs in Cookeville
Tennessee
done you have to move if you're going to
do that you gotta at least get to
Nashville you gotta at least be in a
metropolitan area minimum Nashville but
obviously New York or L.A even Atlanta
yeah and and Nashville's got a lot of
film work going on a lot of stuff
happening but it's not exactly Nirvana
for actors right right either so uh it
might be for music people sorta but the
uh anyway so you've got a location issue
if you're going to be there that must be
true you can't live in Cookeville and do
your dream
that's one thing so you just you have to
start saying okay what are my barriers
what are my blockers and I'm going to
knock those down and I think the next
thing you've got to do too is what Jade
was indicating is you need to find
something making 50 to 60 000 a year
working 40 to 80 hours a week to start
piling up some money so that you can
afford to work on entering into the
entertainment business which is you have
to have the side Hustle the side gig and
it may last a decade until you break
into those businesses that's right
whether it's music business acting
business or whatever the joke in
Nashville is how do you get the next
country music star's attention uh waiter
and I know it's possible like I think
sometimes people in the Arts they kind
of have that well it's be I'm broke
because I'm in the Arts no man like
you're broke because you ain't working
yeah man Sam and I went to dinner the
other night and the valet was parked in
the car and I went to tip him and I said
you know do you have the QR code so I
can tip you he said yeah he gives me his
card with the QR code on it he's a
guitar player yeah and he's a musician
but he's working as a valet and I'm
guessing he probably has a good job he's
high-end restaurant he's making bangs he
was at a high-end restaurant so don't
talk yourself out of the fact that you
can't make money until you become a
successful actor that's a lie two
blockers I see immediately is location
for your long-term dream and willingness
to do a whole bunch of side hustle Big
Time fast yeah you know why you took the
security job at the venue because you
wanted to be around entertainment not
because it was a good job yeah
you're still you just want to be around
it because you love it you love the
stage you love watching those people on
the stage dream and you're going to be
that guy someday and you might be I hope
you are but the security gig is not I
mean obviously he's not making a lot of
money and commuting from cookful to do
it is just plain mathematically
ridiculous yeah just does not work so
you know you're you're working all the
time and there's plenty of work and it's
not education based at all there's
plenty of work from retail to
restaurants to Uber to cutting grass to
construction uh man there's construction
jobs on Nashville there's more cranes in
Nashville on the skyline right now than
there are buildings so it's just you
know there is all kinds of work you can
do at 20 to 40 bucks an hour in a town
like Nashville if you can't find that in
Cookeville now Cookeville is not a small
town anymore right and everybody in
Cookeville is not at the poverty line I
can promise you that that's true and I
know several multi-millionaires there
personally you know I've said it before
it and I'll say it again when it comes
to this stuff you've gotta until you
write it down on paper step by step what
your what your steps in this process are
going to be it's floating around in your
head and it's causing chaos and it's
causing you to either paralyze you and
not do anything at all or it's just
causing you to go in a million
directions you got to get this on paper
and write down all right stuff my
desired future and I'm Stephen is to be
in the acting world in the film world
I've got two things I have I immediately
see already in a five minute
conversation yeah we move
and we work side hustles more to eat
really really well while we're pursuing
this dream then there's probably more
blockers that have to do with actually
entering into that industry
there you go I don't know anything about
that stuff you need to get an agent
because your agent's going to give you
feedback onto what you need to do next
to actually be able to land work so make
sure you're sending your things out to
people who will give you so happy and
we're going to send you proximity
principle by Ken Coleman and from
paycheck to purpose by Ken Coleman which
both deal with these issues you're a
good man I'm honored to talk to you
thank you for calling that puts us out
of the Ramsay show in the books we'll be
back with you before you know it in the
meantime remember there's ultimately
only one way to financial peace and
that's to walk daily with the Prince of
Peace Christ Jesus
hey what's up guys it's Jade look if you
like what you heard in this episode and
want to know more about getting started
on the Ramsay baby steps go to
ramsesolutions.com and click the get
started button we'll help you figure out
the best next step for you based on your
specific situation that's
ramseysolutions.com and click get
started
[Music]